oh I'm here about the receptionist job  hi oh you gonna call chris hemsworth he  has no idea what they even do what's  this place called again  Chris place Kevin the receptionist not a  bimbo exactly more of a don't listen  covered as eyes kevin is a big dumb  puppy dog oh that's not a bad thing as  our Kevin found out during his  ghostbusters that visit Woolsey life  funny every so positive adjectives you  could have this person starts to sound  like he's paid at all I know it's a Ken  doll with the inside scoop down Kevin  can I ask why no no glass I just kept  getting dirty sorry I took him out Kevin  thinks he's gonna become a Ghostbuster  too we need to form a group and build  something to fight these damn ghosts  that's exactly what we already do here  Mars Lonnie doesn't matter its person's  worth well more of that vine is being  fun well debut online tomorrow ahead of  an Administrative Professionals Day  which is Wednesday